enfant déjà étonné ce comme à rêver de
ses comédiens ambulants sa vie déraper
poutine est là le baron de sigognac 2017
soit 4 par tomber les ronds de france
qui s'y engouffrent
la grande métaphore de la vie et en plus
dans le cra casillas il autres thèmes
toujours fasciné c'est de vivre le
voyage le temps qui passe qui charge ou
au change pas les aurons la grande
histoire qui jeu se promène sur les
terres de l'histoire individuelle donc
sur deux thèmes qui nous toujours très
secret c'est le personnage ou à partir
très faible plus fragiles très cuillère
de tout cas il connaît rien et c'est fou
il faut apprendre à travers un voyage à
travers l'amour la guerre la souffrance
et il trouve son identité et je pensais
que perez et je crois qu il y manque
quelque chose
ou souffrance n'y sont pas elle suit son
parce qu'elle est ridicule d'ailleurs
une histoire sans douleur d'après paris
ce que la demande d'être de contempler
le film une demande de travail ou se
laisser séduire par le film et non pas
de de rentrer dedans à denain d'analyser
les choses et de de rentrer dans un
rythme sain non au contraire fait juste
spectateurs et se laisser séduire par le
film comme comment se fait c'est dur par
un parent un tableau ou par un paysage
musique triste viendrait
les pillages sont ceux des sentiments
des voyages un peu
non c est pratique pour le plaisir ce
fait est légal pour eux comme pour vous
que je vous dise une chose mais nous
lettre mon petit tracas est horrible
mais petit épouse au cours de ces
dernières années
pierrette et les considérables non grata